thirty-five dollars it can buy you a
sweater from the gap a bouquet of
flowers two large pizzas or a new
computer or a new computer no seriously
this is the $35 Raspberry Pi 2 and it's
a bare-bones computer that's much faster
than the previous version it isn't much
it doesn't come with a mouse a keyboard
even a power cord but that's sort of the
point it's meant to encourage kids and
even us adults to build tinker and
engage more with our computers but don't
let that scare you you can do quite a
bit with this little thing even if
you're like me and don't have any coding
experience you just need a lot of time
and a little patience I've been using
the Raspberry Pi as my main computer for
the better half of the week sure at
times it got so slow that I had time to
do some yoga but actually I could do far
more than I anticipated on it because
there's no hard drive the PI doesn't
come with an operating system instead
beginners should buy raspbian Linux on a
micro SD card for just $10 I put in the
card plugged in an HDMI monitor Ethernet
cable and USB mouse and keyboard and was
up and running yes you do have to type
some things into the command line to get
started but believe it or not it took
less time to set up the computer than to
bake a real Raspberry Pi once I was set
up I could check and write emails surf
the web I downloaded a word processing
program from the PI store and spent far
too much time trying to build a house in
Minecraft pi I also learned how to
control this little cat in scratch a
program for kids meant to teach coding
guys he's walking but not everything is
fun and games for example getting the
Wi-Fi and sound to work was so
frustrating I felt like tossing the darn
thing in a pie the second thing I was
able to do turn the little box into an
Apple TV or chromecast replacement after
installing os MC software that turns the
pie into a media center I plugged the
box into my TV and downloaded a
compatible remote control app on my
phone
it wasn't long before I was watching
YouTube clips and even streaming videos
from my iphone to the TV using airplay
there's no Netflix or Hulu and even just
accessing those through a browser is
hard with the lack of support for
different software but the price and
popularity of the Raspberry Pi means you
can actually tinker with the hardware to
create some weird and wondrous
inventions there's actually a Raspberry
Pi in here adafruit.com run by Lee Moore
freeze makes it sells PI compatible
hardware tools and post tutorials on how
to put them together I got together with
me more in person and she walked me
through a beginner project of creating a
PI powered stepper motor that spins a
small flag we went through a few of the
steps including attaching wires on the
motor to the PI I did it congratulations
go forth and make know this PI isn't for
everyone you can spend hours being
frustrated with a computer that's far
slower than many $200 Windows PCs but
for the curious and the patient that's
time spent learning how the computers
around us work and hey it's only $35 and
much lower in carbs
damn this PI's good